Buenos días María Clara esta meta el
treinta fue la meta bandera a lo largo
de todas estas dos semanas en este en
esta importante Cumbre que se realizó en
Montreal Así que cerrar sin esa meta
aprobada hubiera sido visto para los
negociadores como un fracaso
Así que el ambiente es muy positivo con
el logro de esta meta y esta meta
permite que el acuerdo Montreal se pueda
considerar histórico y que pase a hacer
un acuerdo en segundo nivel de
importancia después del acuerdo de París
en el que se fijaba el uno coma cinco de
Máximo de grados para calentamiento
global Así que es una meta bastante
histórica pero no es la única que se
logró también se logró la reducción
entre las metas que se plantean de
pesticidas de aquí a los próximos años
hasta 2030 en un 50% así como el
desperdicio de alimentos y muy
importante en el tema financiero que fue
muy polémico la aprobación de doscientos
mil millones de millones de dólares al
año para financiar estas metas y sobre
todo para los países en desarrollo que
estuvieron planteando su su postura a lo
largo de la Cumbre la aprobación de
flujo financieros de veinte mil millones
de dólares de aquí a 2025 y 30 mil
millones de dólares hasta 2030 sí
Carolina pero como usted mencionaba el
tema de la financiación fue clave y la
República democrática del Congo no
estuvo de acuerdo con el pacto final
Cómo fueron Esas últimas horas de
negociación
las últimas horas de negociación fueron
bastante tensas la última plenaria se
realizó el sábado en la tarde y en la
plenaria el ministro ambiente de Bolivia
lanzado multimátum a los países en
desarrollo y les pedía presentar una
propuesta que estuviera a la altura del
nivel de ambición que se quería en este
marco eh posteriormente al día siguiente
ayer domingo en la presidencia de la cop
el ministro ambiente chino presentó una
propuesta final un último borrador y los
y los ministros Y delegados estuvieron
discutiendo toda la tarde de este
domingo hasta la madrugada de de hoy que
se logró finalmente llegar al